Hello, I'm a researcher at Portswigger, the makers of Burp Suite, and I'd like to share
with you today some of the research that I've been working on.
So welcome to Portable Data Exfiltration, XSS for PDFs.
In this talk, I'm going to show you how to booby trap a PDF document, track when a PDF
was opened and closed even when loaded from a file system, and exfiltrate the contents
of an unknown PDF on both Chrome and Acrobat.
All these techniques use a PDF injection.
My colleague, James Kettle, was watching a Black Hat talk about PDFs, and he was looking
at the code and thought to himself, this looks injectable.
And he got back to the office and we had the following conversation.
He said, PDF code is totally injectable.
And I responded, I think it's impossible.
You wouldn't know the structure of a PDF.
The XRF table would break, the objects would break.
How could this be possible?
But that didn't stop me there.
I then began to test for PDF injection.
So we're going to cover injection theory, how user input can get inside PDFs, why you just
can't inject arbitrary content.
I'll talk about my methodology, the vulnerable libraries that I encountered, and then we'll
go on to exploiting injections in Chrome and Acrobat as well as a hybrid injection.
Then I'll wrap up with defense, leaving five minutes for questions.
Server side PDF generation is everywhere.
It's in invoices, in receipts, in e-tickets, in payslips, in boarding passes.
The list is endless.
So there's plenty of opportunity to get user input inside a PDF document.
If you imagine a PDF injection as an XSS injection, and imagine you're injecting inside parentheses,
this is very similar to what happens when you're injecting inside PDF code.
Like JavaScript, you have to ensure that the syntax is valid.
This means repairing the parentheses before your injection, as well as the parentheses after
the injection.
So, the PDF is structured into objects, XRF table and trailer.
There are more parts to it, but just for the purposes of this talk, I'm going to focus on
these three parts.
So the objects allow you to define text streams and images, for example.
The XRF table contains a list of all the objects in the document.
And the trailer appears at the end of the document that defines the root object.
So this is what an object looks like, very simplified in a PDF document.
So this is the first object indicated by number one.
And the revision is zero.
And the OBJ is the start object marker.
Then we have the start of a new dictionary.
And we have a dictionary key here, in this case, pages.
And the value of the dictionary key, in this instance, is 2 space 0 space R.
This indicates it's a reference.
So it's looking for the second object, revision number zero, somewhere in that document.
So the pages dictionary key allows you to define the amount of pages in the document.
And in this instance, we're using a reference to the second object, which will define that
information.
And that's the end of the dictionary here.
This is the XRF table.
It begins with the XRF keyword.
This is the first object in the XRF table.
And that begins at position number 10.
So at the 10th position in the document is where the first object begins.
And using the start XRF keyword, this will tell you where in the document the XRF table begins.
In this instance, it's at 413.
So I'm going to talk about parsing briefly, just so you can understand how the PDF document is parsed.
This doesn't contain the whole thing, just enough information for the talk.
So first the start XRF is read and it points to the XRF table.
Each of the objects is then read in the XRF table.
And then all the references are followed.
Our most likely injection point might occur in the objects themselves.
And then the payload is executed inside the object.
And then the document is rendered.
So one likely injection point is in a text stream.
So here we define an object, which is object number four, the length.
And it's a stream and BT indicates the begin text.
We define the fonts and the font size.
And then we define the text itself, which is hello world.
So an injection could occur here.
So you can inject here.
You could inject a closing parenthesis, for example, break out of that code and allow you to define a new object.
But the problem we have here is we can inject a new object, but the XRF table wouldn't be updated.
So that object would never get rendered.
So you could see why I thought it was impossible to do PDF injection.
But this is annotations and annotations are great.
So you could see why I'm going to use the text.
So why I'm going to use the text.
So I was testing around eight different libraries.
And I came up with the following methodology.
To test them.
Identify construct and exploit.
So first you identify.
Can you inject parentheses or backslashes?
So a library should escape.
Parenthesis and backslashes.
In URI dictionaries or text streams.
If they don't escape any of those characters.
Or one of those characters.
Then there could be PDF injection in the library.
I also tried multiby characters.
For example, 5C29.
Which is the backslash.
And the closing parenthesis.
So the idea here would be.
To inject a multiby character.
The library would then convert them.
To single byte characters.
Which then may allow those.
Dangerous characters to cause PDF injection.
I also tried things like.
Ascii range overflow.
So adding a character.
Over the Ascii range.
That might get converted.
Into another character.
Like parenthesis or backslash.
I also tried.
Causing errors.
In the.
PDF rendering process.
By injecting nulls.
Or end of file markers.
Or comments.
Once you've identified.
The library is vulnerable.
Then you can try.
And find a site.
That uses this library.
So then you need to construct a PDF.
From the.
Injection.
That.
Has.
A callback.
By either.
Calling alert one.
If you know the structure of the PDF.
And you can render it.
Or a callback.
By using the.
Submit form function.
Which would.
Post to external URL.
This would be useful.
In blind situations.
Where you.
Don't know the structure.
Or content of the PDF.
But you can still cause an injection.
Also.
With clients.
That do not support.
JavaScript.
You can use the.
Submit form action.
And also.
Do a callback.
So once you've identified.
That your PDF is rendered.
And you've.
Got a callback.
Then you can.
Exploit it.
And you can.
By stealing the contents.
Of the PDF.
Using JavaScript.
Or without JavaScript.
Using.
Submit form actions.
So I tested.
Around eight.
Different vulnerable.
Eight different.
PDF libraries.
And the first one.
That I encountered.
Is.
I encountered.
The first one.
That I encountered.
Is.
The first one.
That I encountered.
Is.
The first one.
That I encountered.
That was vulnerable.
Was.
PDF.
High from lib.
This has.
Over 52,000.
Weekly downloads.
And they made.
A crucial mistake.
So.
This job.
Generates.
A PDF.
Document.
Using their library.
And.
They made a mistake.
In the PDF.
String helper.
So if we zoom in.
The URI.
Of the annotation.
Is defined here.
And.
The first one.
That I encountered.
That was vulnerable.
Was.
Is defined here.
And.
The.
It uses the PDF.
String.
Of helper.
And.
We can inject.
Into.
This helper.
And.
You can inject.
Parenthesis.
And the.
Aren't escaped.
So this allows you to.
Inject code.
Into the annotation.
And.
Define your own.
Annotations.
And.
The next library.
I encountered.
Was.
The.
JS PDF.
Library.
This.
Has.
Over.
A quarter.
Of a million.
Weekly.
Downloads.
So it's quite popular.
And they.
Made.
A similar mistake.
So.
Here.
We define.
That annotation.
Has.
A URL.
Property.
When you.
Create.
The annotation.
And.
That URL.
Property.
Is also.
Vulnerable.
Similar to.
The.
Other library.
That showed you.
So you can.
Inject.
Parenthesis.
And inject.
Your own.
PDF.
Code.
So.
Now.
I'm going to.
Talk about.
Exploiting.
Injections.
Injection.
So.
First.
We.
Break out.
Of.
The.
PDF.
String.
The.
Gray.
Code.
Is.
The.
Black.
Code.
Is.
Actually.
Our.
Injection.
So.
We.
Break out.
The.
New.
Action.
In this.
Case.
Which.
Call.
And.
Then.
We.
Repair.
The.
Existing.
Action.
Using.
Slash.
Parenthesis.
Which.
Allows.
You.
To.
Create.
Valid.
Syntax.
In PDF.
And.
Doesn't.
Cause.
It's a.
To.